if you ever you know go places then 2016
has been a big year for you after 12
months of cars starting to drive
themselves cities getting smarter drones
taking off let's take a look back at our
five favorite transportation related
moments of the year first up in
September uber launched the country's
first fleet of autonomous taxis in
Pittsburgh it's just a pilot program
with human drivers at the wheel for
safety but it's also a rare chance for
regular citizens to ride in the future
here we go and it's our first real look
at how on-demand self-driving
transportation services will enter our
lives but autonomy is about more than
cars that's about trucks too which is
great news partly because trucks don't
have the best safety record and partly
because sometimes they carry beer in
October auto the self-driving truck
company uber bought this year made the
world's first autonomous commercial
delivery hauling fifty thousand cans of
budweiser across Colorado bottoms up
okay you're probably bored by the word
regulation but this one's important so
listen up this summer the feds finally
released new rules using a lot of the
major restrictions on flying drones for
commercial reasons the buzzing UAVs
still don't have the right to drop
amazon packages on your front lawn but
with this new regime in place and
written for a world of drones it's
likely only a matter of time before that
changes of course tech giants aren't the
only ones shaping the future this year
the Department of Transportation pushed
cities to plan for a world where
congestion is worse infrastructure is
broken ER and more people than ever are
trying to move around columbus ohio snag
the 50 million dollar first prize but
the dozens of cities that competed each
get a consolation gift they've already
done the planning for the future now
they just need to make it happen
to round out the year let's remember
that the age of gas power and human
driving isn't over just yet in March
Bugatti revealed the sheer on perhaps
the most extravagant car ever for just
2.6 million dollars that's a base price
of course you get 1,500 horsepower 1200
pound feet of torque for turbochargers a
top speed electronically limited to 260
miles an hour and two seats the shira
maybe the high-water mark of the first
age of the automobile but it's also one
hell of a closing
you